[Música]
olá meu nome é felipe setembro em fos eu
sou aluno do 5º ano
hoje eu vou falar sobre uma pessoa que
já foi homenageada por dez presidentes
da república e vocês me perguntam o que
isso tem a ver com a síndrome de down
ah e mais uma coisa a síndrome de down é
causada por uma diferença no cromossomo
o que a promoção o cromossomo ficar
dentro da sua cela é como se fosse um
manual de instruções do seu corpo
o que acontece com um cromossomo na
síndrome de down
durante a gravidez lan no comecinho
quando só existia a primeira célula
acontece um probleminha chamado mutação
e as células ao invés de serem 46
cromossomos saem com 47 atrapalhando no
manual de instruções do corpo
isso leva a síndrome de down algumas
características que as pessoas que têm
síndrome de down intenção e olhos
puxadinhos por ele as mais baixas
precisam de mais ajuda para aprender e
tomar muito cuidado com o coração ajuda
que eles precisam são educadores
especiais fonoaudiólogos médicos
fisioterapeutas e sempre de muito
estímulo e do que eles são capazes
eles são capazes de ler e escrever serem
bons esportistas tocar instrumentos
musicais namorar ter uma profissão que
era uma autonomia mas com supervisão
agora vou falar pra vocês que um caso
muito mais que especial
renata 41 anos portadora da síndrome de
down e também a tia trabalha em uma
empresa muito grande e sonha cursar
uma faculdade e se casar já participou
de uma paraolimpíada já ganhou vários
outros mundiais
vários outros em parapanamericanos para
os outros brasileiros já foi eleita
cinco vezes melhor atleta do ano já
bateu diversos recordes brasileiros e
muito mais
ela fez tanto pelo brasil que foi
recebida por dois presidentes da
república fernando henrique e fernando
collor
agora antes de acabar a minha palestra
eu gostaria de deixar uma mensagem para
vocês
os portadores da síndrome de down devem
ser tratados da mesma forma que todos
nós como vocês puderam ver eles são
capazes de turno desde que incentivados
estimulados
obrigado
[Aplausos]